hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to minecraft now I know it's
been a long time since the last time I
played this game but that's kind of a
good thing because there's been an
incredible number of updates to the game
like 11 full updates to the game since
the last time I played it so I thought
the best way to get into this which is
going to be a very long term series I'm
probably gonna do maybe a hundred parts
of this before I'll get through all the
new stuff but I thought the best place
to start would be just to create a new
world call it what I want to call it
I'll call it markiplier is fun house and
then just get into it and start
exploring from the ground up because
sometimes you just got to get your hands
dirty when you're playing a new game and
really start fresh because what you
think you know can get in the way of
what you will discover in the world so I
uh man it's been a while since I play
this it's been a while since I've been
back in the Minecraft world and you know
I gotta say it's good to be back it's
good to be uh it's good to be back into
this whole environment and one of the
things that I like the most about
Minecraft has always been the music and
the sound and the ambience because where
it doesn't have graphics is where it
might have some more experience to
discover and as usual this hasn't
changed I know you guys are wondering
like oh man is the very basic building
blocks of the game different the answer
is no and you still punch wood to get it
I don't know I don't know it's charming
at this point just the fact that you're
slamming your bony fists into a hunk of
wood and hoping that it'll it'll it'll
smash to pieces before your your brittle
skeleton does but you know you just do
what you can with what you got and if
you've forgotten oh there's my little
guy I still get an achievement for
taking inventory but it's all the same
you just craft up a storm oh man I'm
getting ahead of myself I totally forgot
how to play you got to make wood first
and then make a table out of that
because once you add the crafting table
you're still able to make all of the
other basic fundamental building blocks
of this entire game because it starts
from the very you know early stages of
what you're supposed to do and then
grows into something even bigger and
better now you may be seeing I don't
know what this
is this a sheen or something I have no
idea field ah I don't even know where to
begin with this
[Music]